I was assuming we would start Today's
Show by talking about the new Republican
Speaker of the House of Representatives
because after all Republicans took over
even though it was by a small margin the
control of the house based on their wins
in the 2022 midterm election November
8th and it was time yesterday for them
to select a new speaker of the house but
no they have not done it and Republicans
are in the midst of what is one of the
biggest humiliating
self-inflicted embarrassments in recent
American political history Republicans
have suffered a true humiliation failing
to elect a speaker of the house after
three rounds of voting the house
ultimately adjourning yesterday without
speaker and they will start again today
and they they're likely already going
right now as you listen to today's
program most Republicans voting for
Kevin McCarthy but not all there is a
faction that has opted not to support
Kevin McCarthy and this actually led to
Hakeem Jeffries on the Democratic side
with Democrats United behind Jeffries
actually coming closer to the 218 votes
that are needed then McCarthy in some of
the votes CNBC has a good nice concise
article about it by Christina Wilkie the
House of Representatives adjourned for
the day Tuesday without a speaker after
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy failed
three consecutive votes to secure enough
support to be selected to the post this
is a historic situation it's an historic
situation some are even saying it's the
first time in a hundred years
that the majority party failed to
coalesce around a candidate to speaker
in this number of votes and we don't
know what the step is the next step is
at this point in time we will get to
that
um after the first ballot resulted in
votes for several Republicans the next
two rounds saw McCarthy's opponents
coalesce around a new Contender
Congressman Jim Jordan of Ohio a
longtime McCarthy Ally Jim Jordan says
he doesn't want it and Lauren Beau bear
and Scott Perry are saying Jim Jordan is
sort of like George Washington George
Washington didn't want to be president
but he did it and they are talking about
Jim Jordan in the same delusional terms
which we will get to a little bit later
what does this mean for the long term of
the Republican party's ability to
I I was going to say govern but it's
like they don't really plan to govern
they govern they plan to investigate
Hunter Biden which we will also get to a
little bit later uh but this is
embarrassing and Tucker Carlson is
saying it's becoming a joke Sean Hannity
is saying that it is becoming a joke and
we don't exactly know the direction this
will ultimately go uh the CNBC article
also
um pointing out during each of the three
voice votes every Democrat rallied
unanimously around incoming minority
leader Hakeem Jeffries a former guest on
on this program by the way but a sect of
conservative Republicans split from
their party to back other candidates
including Jim Jordan as I mentioned in
an unexpected twist McCarthy lost
support as the voting continued which is
just hilarious to see when in the third
round Florida Republican Congressman
Byron Donalds announced his support for
Jordan after voting twice for McCarthy
as a result of Donald's defection
McCarthy got 202 of the 218 votes needed
Jeffries got 212.
um getting uh quite close in fact now is
it likely
that Hakeem Jeffries is going to be the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
it is not likely and there are headlines
saying could Democrats end up with the
speakership
um I don't believe that it is likely I
believe a more likely scenario is if
Republicans don't move to someone else
that some Democrats end up joining the
majority of Republicans but AOC is
saying that's not going to happen and
that Democrats are going to remain
United so I I think the least likely
scenario is Hakeem Jeffries becomes the
speaker of the house but it's not a zero
chance and man that would be
unbelievable so that's what happened
yesterday I have no news for you about
the next speaker of the house maybe we
will later today but of course everyone
on the Republican side weighing in about
this one of those people
the failed former president Donald Trump
let's talk about that because it's quite
interesting
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below